خلاصة القول هي
أن الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤنا وشركائنا
سوف يدعمون الشعب الأوكراني ،
وسنحاسب روسيا على
أفعالها ، والغرب موحد
وقررنا أن نفرض
عقوبات شديدة على روسيا إذا
غزت أوكرانيا
مرة أخرى ، لكنني أقول مرة أخرى
لا يزال بإمكان روسيا اختيار الدبلوماسية
، فلم يفت الأوان بعد للتوقف عن التصعيد
والعودة إلى طاولة المفاوضات
الليلة الماضية ،
وافقت روسيا على أن
يجتمع وزير الخارجية لينكولن ووزير الخارجية لافروف
في 24
فبراير في 24 فبراير في أوروبا ،
ولكن إذا اتخذت روسيا إجراءً عسكريًا من
قبل  سيكون واضحًا في ذلك التاريخ
أنهم أغلقوا الباب أمام الدبلوماسية
، سيكونون قد
اختاروا الحرب وسيدفعون ثمنًا باهظًا
لفعل ذلك
ليس فقط من العقوبات التي
سوف نفرضها نحن وحلفاؤنا على روسيا ولكن أيضًا
غاضبًا من أن يزورهم بقية العالم ، كما
تعلمون
للعديد من القضايا لتقسيم أمتنا وعالمنا ،
لكن الوقوف في وجه العدوان الروسي هو
لا أحد منهم
، الشعب الأمريكي موحد ،
أوروبا متحد ، مجتمع عبر الأطلسي
متحد ، أحزابنا السياسية
في هذا البلد متحدون ،
العالم الحر بأكمله متحد ، روسيا لديها
خيار بين الحرب وكل المعاناة
التي ستجلبها أو الدبلوماسية
التي ستجعل  مستقبل أكثر أمانًا للجميع